- [Interviewer] And then,
he gave me his lighter.
- A church lighter.
(Wizard giggling)
- [Man] A church lighter,
yeah.
- This some good vanilla out here, though.
- [Man] Easy, I got you.
- M-hm.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Wizard Silver Dollar.
Wizard, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Wizard] Washington, DC.
- [Interviewer] And, that's
where you're based today?
- [Wizard] I'm all over the globe.
- [Interviewer] But, you started in DC?
- Yes.
- How'd you grow up?
You have both your parents as a kid?
- Yeah, I had both my parents growing up.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- It was great, let me tell it.
(Interviewer giggling)
- Yeah.
I had a good childhood.
- [Interviewer] No crazy abuse?
Nothing like that?
- Nah, none of that type stuff.
Uh-uh.
- [Interviewer] At what point
did you start working as a pimp?
- When I was 21.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you get the idea?
From friends or...
Do you have role models?
Anything like that?
- Well, it basically came from...
I can say it's in my blood.
For one, I got an older
uncle that was a pimp, and...
But, I had other cousin's
and stuff that was looking
at doing it and stuff like that,
and they used to be talking about it,
and riding down a track
and stuff like that.
And, I used to be just sitting back,
and getting high and stuff,
and doing my thing,
when I was doing the stuff in the streets,
but when I was looking
at the movies with them
and they talking about it,
I'd realize that was me.
So, then once I realized that,
we had all type of
chicks that we was like,
running trains and shit on.
You know, doing stuff that
young dudes do with chicks
and I picked one of the main chicks
that was really going.
Like, rolling and stuff.
And, I told her,
did you wanna come fuck with this pimping.
You know, we can get some
money and shit like that,
so she was with it.
And then, from there on, I just went
and kept going up.
- [Interviewer] So, you've been doing this
for how many years?
- About 20.
20 years.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you married?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Have you been
arrested for this before?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Was that trafficking?
- Pandering.
- [Interviewer] Pandering.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, you
travel around the country?
- M-hm.
- [Interviewer] How does it
work in different cities?
Like, in Vegas, you're in casinos?
- Yeah, it works different
in different cities.
You know, the casinos in Vegas,
then you got the tracks
in different states,
and stuff like that,
with the prostitutes or the whole strobe.
Then, you got the internet.
You know, it's all type of ways
that you can get money outta dudes.
- [Interviewer] How many girls
do you have in your stable?
- Well, I got like four girls
that play their part in my congregation.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What races are your girls?
- Black and Spanish.
- [Interviewer] And, you
have sex with the girls?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So, the pimp style
has changed over the years?
You seem to be from the old school.
Stylish dresser, flashy car.
- I'd say I come up under the
last of the old school breed.
You know?
Nowadays it's like more
of the young school.
You know, the Jordans.
You know, the young cats.
You know, the young dressed, the jerseys
and all that type shit, you know?
But, I guess they just
don't know no better.
- [Interviewer] You have more style.
- Yeah, they can't fuck with me.
- [Interviewer] What are
the quality a pimp needs
to thrive?
- The qualities?
- [Interviewer] What personality traits?
- To be a good one, you
just need to be a man,
period, overall.
You know, you gotta know
how to treat people.
You gotta serve respect, 'cause
you wanna be respected back.
You know?
And, you just gotta wanna be the best
at whatever you wanna do.
Period.
And, I believe that's in anything.
- [Interviewer] So, what about
the girls in your stable?
- What'd you say?
- [Interviewer] What qualities
do you look for in a girl?
- Loyalty.
I like go-getters.
I like them to have ambition
to want to go get money.
You know, and they listen.
You know, they gotta be able to listen.
- [Interviewer] So,
what's the arrangement?
How much of their money do you take?
- [Wizard] 100 percent.
I need it all.
- [Interviewer] So, what's
the girl get out of it?
- [Wizard] She gets taken care of.
She keeps money, too.
I ain't gonna have her
walking around broke.
These grown women.
- [Interviewer] What do you
do when one of your girls
gets out of line?
- [Wizard] Communicate.
That's the key.
I don't put my hands on 'em.
- [Man] You don't?
- [Wizard] No.
- [Interviewer] And, what do you do
when one of your girls
gets a customer who's
giving her a hard time,
gets in trouble?
- [Wizard] Well, I teach
'em how to handle themself
when I'm not around.
So, they have to handle themself,
and if it's a problem
where I can help out,
I'll go on with assist.
My chicks like family.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think the relationship
a girl has with her pimp
is somehow a substitute
for the relationship
she had with her father?
- [Wizard] Yes, definitely.
- [Interviewer] They call you daddy?
- [Wizard] Definitely.
Not all of them,
but a lot do.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
a part of the picture
for your girls?
- [Wizard] I don't like
drugs part of the picture.
But, I don't really accept
girls that do hard drugs.
- [Interviewer] What's the craziest thing
you've seen in all your
years of doing this?
- [Wizard] The craziest thing?
I seen so many crazy things.
I mean, crazy things is like
when you talk about girls
getting raped, robbed,
and stuff like that,
and shot at, and stuff.
You know, all that's basically
in the same category.
It's just a bad situation.
And, it goes down.
- [Interviewer] What's the
longest one of your girls
has stayed with you?
- Three years.
- [Man] Three years.
- [Interviewer] If you
hadn't become a pimp,
what other careers do you
think you might've followed?
- I was always in the
streets, to be honest.
So, I never liked really working hard.
So, like dealing drugs and all that,
standing outside and all that,
I aint really never was with that.
You know, I gotta survive.
So, I did what I had to do and stuff,
but I liked...
I never liked to work hard,
so no telling what I'd
be doing, to be honest.
No telling what I'd be doing.
- [Interviewer] What are you
proudest of in your life?
- The proudest?
Of how I've changed my life.
That's the proudest.
I changed my life for the better
in working my way out of the streets,
and being more in my kid's life,
and being able to take
care of my kids and stuff.
So, I had to learn to elevate my game
to another level,
'cause it's always gonna be in me.
I'ma always be the person that I am.
But, I just gotta learn.
I had to learn to put myself in situations
where I can't in no trouble
and stuff like that.
And, still could be me,
and still don't have to work hard,
and could still be successful.
And overall, my kids love me.
- [Interviewer] Are you raising your kids?
- Yes, I help take care of them.
They don't stay with me, but you know,
I help take care of them.
They come visit me.
My Kids getting older and stuff like that,
so they come visit me,
and I go visit them,
and I move around so much,
so I could just go pop up on them.
And, they getting older,
so they can pop up on me.
- [Interviewer] Do they know
what dad does for a living?
- Yeah, I be honest with
my kids about everything.
- [Interviewer] Do you have boys or girls?
- Both.
- [Interviewer] What
happens if one of your kids
decides to follow in your footsteps,
or work for somebody like yourself?
- All I can do is really talk to them.
Like I told you, communication is the key.
So, all I can do is talk to 'em,
and you know, give 'em other options.
You know, let them know other
options that they can go,
and could still...
You know, it's a lot of ways to get money,
and get rich, and wealthy.
And, you know, so I'd just,
you know, show 'em other ways and stuff.
And, let them know stuff
that I've been through
and that can come with it.
And, it's a good chance
that it can come with it.
- [Interviewer] Did you
graduate high school?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] You
started at what age, again?
- 21, I was 21.
20, 21.
- [Interviewer] Can you tell me more
about your beginnings as a pimp?
Yeah.
It went down like I was telling you.
Like, we was having girls
that we was, you know,
I had like little roller chicks
that everybody was you know sleeping with
and stuff like that.
And, I got the main one,
that was like the leader
of all the other girls
and stuff like that.
So, once she was with it,
she basically got put to the test,
'cause I bought her around.
You know, people that
was already having sex
with her and stuff like that.
But now, we done, you know, communicate,
and we say we was going
to be on the same page,
and we gone get this money together.
You know, let's see how this works
when you get around now.
So, once we got around now,
she failed the test.
You know, and somebody had
did something with her.
You dig what I'm saying?
So like, now I was being tested
on what I was gonna do
about the situation.
You know?
And, I checked the chick
about the situation,
and after I checked her,
you know, I aint had 'em problems no more.
You know?
So, that was the test for me and her.
And, it went on from there.
And, I just gradually
kept growing and growing.
And, confidence kept getting bigger.
And, I always knew I could be
the best at whatever I did.
You know?
So, that's what went down.
And, we gone keep this thing pushing.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Wizard Silver Dollar,
thank you so much for sharing our story,
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
Thanks.
- Fo show.
It's all love.
Yeah.
Church.